I am so excited for the season finale
it's gonna be so incredible the season
six finale of Pretty Little Liars is
finally here and we caught up with star
Ashley Benson to get the exclusive scoop
on all the danger ahead
yeah what was your reaction when you
read this finale script I was very
excited yeah
yeah I got to do some really cool things
and the finale is like it's just very
different from we've done before there's
so many emotions and like I think the
reason why it's one my favorites too
because you get to see what happened at
like Hanna and Caleb like their breakup
and this and that and they're super cool
shots that I got to do in the rain and
it's like slow-motion I saw that in the
preview I was like yes and there's a
twin that's going to be revealed a lot
of people think that it's Hanna's twin
well I was gonna say do you think that
Hanna could have a twin in two and what
would that twin be like um I definitely
think I could have a twin I hope that
she has a twin I'm like yes we need to
Hanna now what was your reaction when
you found out that Haila
was gonna be breaking up this season
because the fans are a little bit upset
I cried like literally I cried I was I
was so upset I was like you have to
change it there's no way there's no
other guy for Hanna and then when I
found out he was gonna be a Spencer I
was like there's no way like you could
not be with Spencer I was literally
crying I called town I was like you'll
never believe what I just heard he's
like what I'm like we're not gonna get
married I thought we're gonna get
married have kids like all this stuff
and then I find out that we're breaking
up I was like I think I was more
depressed out of anybody out of any of
the fans I'm still depressed like I go
on YouTube and look at Hanna and Caleb
videos 24th of it cuz I'm just like so
that's bad